I am happy most happy to introduce one
of our town's brightest couples the lady
is a star the first magnitude in films
and she's a policewoman on television
the gentleman is an oscar-winning
composer of extraordinary sir
versatility hadn't have mentioned meet
the vacker axe Angie Dickinson invert ha
well before we read the rails you want
to read them their rights you have the
right to remain silent but only if you
lose the nominees for the best original
song are how lucky can you get music and
lyrics by Fred Aaron John Kander ivz
music and lyrics by Keith Carradine now
that we're in love music by George Barry
lyrics by SEMICON Richard's window music
by Charles Fox lyrics by Norman gimbal
theme from mahogany music by Michael
Masser lyrics by Gerry Goffin the winner
is Keith Carradine crazy
I don't believe this I'm incredibly
happy this thing's heavy there's so many
people to thank and so many people that
have given me so much support all the
time I've been acting and singing and
writing first person I want to thank is
Robert often because he's done more for
me than anyone I think and I want to
thank Richard Baskin for all the work
that he put into the score on the film I
want to thank my mother and my father
because without them none of this
could've been possible thanks dad
you